austan Peterson really impressed me with
his constitutional basis in the future
they would be powerful figure heads for
the party Austin Peters and Larry sharp
Austin Peterson definitely I feel it has
the message to carry across the country
we're here at the opening day of the
Libertarian Party National Convention
trying to figure out who will be the
third nominee on all 50 ballots in the
United States in November austin
peterson joins me now Thank You Austin
for coming in and joining us I want to
start by asking you a question that I've
asked everybody here regardless of
whether a candidate or a delegate but it
kind of speaks to what we're all doing
here which is what should be the
libertarian party's goal in a
presidential campaign what's the purpose
of it more than 1% I think we want to
see progress that's what we'd like to
see but what would be amazing for me is
to try and trigger the 12th amendment
let's try and throw this baby into the
house let's go for a real win let's be
strategic let's be smart let's try and
move the ball down the field you can try
the long pass or you can move the ball
down the field with short little passes
so what would be a state that would be
in play that you think potentially
Missouri I did really well in the
primary there I'm well known I'm loved
there I have a community of people who
support me and I'm kind of seeding as a
favorite child in the Midwest by my
hometown so potentially there also Utah
would might be a good one there where a
more pro-life Pro Constitution candidate
might do well Ted Cruz out a lot of
support out there and a lot of those
people have jumped on to my campaign
Mormons are very libertarian so perhaps
that might be a good place for us to go
and try cuz Trump didn't do that well
out there so that might be the place to
go can you walk us through your history
in the libertarian movement and related
organizations in kind of your origin
story sure yeah I may be the youngest
candidate but I'm the longest party
member and I've been the longest
activist for the libertarian cause
specifically so I start out as a street
activist in 2007 I would walk from
subway car to subway car with Ron Paul's
book foreign policy of freedom and I
would rien Paul speeches to the subway
citizens and just interrupt here did you
like wake up one morning and read this
book and it transformed your life or
look how did you get involved
I was inspired when I saw his debate
with Rudy Giuliani and I was paying New
York City income taxes and I was upset
so I wanted a candidate that I could
support and when I saw Ron Paul sort of
smacked down Jolie Giuliani on foreign
policy it was sort of an awakening
moment and I went downtown Manhattan and
myself and twelve other gentlemen turned
that an old nightclub into a 1200
persons strong organization we raise a
million dollars for Ron Paul and then I
got a job with the libertarian party
thanks to that activism I'm very good at
organizing I'm kind of the community
organizer for libertarians and I build
online communities mostly digital
communities of people who are of like
mind and what I learned was that the
libertarian movement when unified and
purpose is very powerful so while I was
working at the libertarian party I put
together a memo with the internship
staff that I had created how to get
libertarians on TV Judge Napolitano who
is another person who I was a great fan
of who had a little podcast on Fox it
was just a little digital thing and so I
stood up one day with David Bose at a
meeting and I said David let's get the
judges on show and that was successful
so I launched a show on Fox Business
from outside of Fox and I became the
judges producer he called me the right
side of his brain and I learned
everything that I know about the
Constitution from the judge and kind of
fought the trenches beside him as his
a-one producer and I think that I'm the
best person to carry these ideas forward
because I can articulate them to the
American people in a way that isn't
quite as off-putting perhaps as some of
our approaches in the past and I'm not
seen as sort of like just a pie in the
sky hi governor you know from New Mexico
where people look at him and say is he
here is he is he awake is he asleep
and and they see me as energetic and
exciting and ready to lead a movement
that I had started on the streets of New
York City in back from Kansas City into
Washington DC your pitch has been
largely to Ted Cruz voters it's been to
Rand Paul voters it's been Mary Madeline
gave you an endorsement people who are
not actually necessarily traditionally
Republicans are you sort of in that cat
if we were if John McAfee is Donald
Trump in the libertarian race Gary
Johnson is I don't know Romney who is
Austin Peterson like what what's your
well
it's a combination of Bernie Sanders and
Barack Obama in a sense you know I was
not really seeing the Bernie Sanders to
be honest with well I'll tell you why
because it's my donor base you know I'm
the grassroots candidate I'm the one
that thousands and thousands of people
are sending their their money in their
change jar to I started this campaign
mailing bumper stickers and licking
stamps by myself and now I have
marshaled the full might of the
grassroots of the libertarian movement
because I know how powerful they can be
and when they have someone that they can
believe in that they know represents
them they're gonna go out in the streets
and they're gonna do the same thing that
I did ten years ago and I know how
powerful that can be in recruitment so
that's what I'm trying to do what would
failure look like for the Libertarian
Party in November what is a numeric
level a psychic level if they don't get
beyond that they will have missed an
opportunity I think probably the same as
they got last time that's why I'm
running is because I was nervous that
there was going to be a half effort so I
decided to run to champion what I
thought was excellence in campaigning
because I I never do something half
measured I always fight as hard as I can
so I thought if it was another repeat of
the ticket that we had last time we
would get the same thing we got last
time the definition of insanity right
doing the same thing expecting different
results so I said hey let's shake it up
let's make a little more wild a little
more fun but principled and still
professional that's the thing still
professional fun while professional
youthful vibrant exciting and that's how
you build a revolution nowadays and so
far so good
should you lose on Sunday would you
endorse the winner absolutely yes I've
worked too hard to grow this party in
this movement to throw it all away for
some hissy fit tantrum just because I'm
losing yeah I lose all the time I have
all kinds of things that don't go well
for me sometimes you know a business
deal doesn't go right and I don't throw
in the towel you just keep trying and to
me you know governor Johnson he's not
ideal but he's a good man and he's done
he's done a good job as a governor of
New Mexico don't care for his VP pick
but I can live with him gosh if he was
Gary Johnson versus Trump or Hillary I'd
be living in a much happier world but
yeah I'll totally endorse governor
Johnson if he wins McAfee too might be
more fun actually we could be a little
more wild
but yeah I've put so many people into
positions of this party where they are
now proud and happy and I feel like if I
would feel like I was abandoning them
and I won't do that
very good awesome Peterson thank you
very much for joining us for reason TV
I'm Matt Welch